feedback starting picture tonight the
right-hander roberto castellanos
only 23 years old and tonight for the
first time he's your starting pitcher
for the diamondbacks garrett hampson
very speedy in center field tonight
there he goes
this is sky to short right josh rojas
out there still coming in
and that's the first down for
castigato's river story down
oh strike three caught him looking at a
curveball first strikeout for roberto
castellanos two outs of the first oh arm
angle gets a little more sweep on that
ball just freezes trevor story that time
popping is at third blackman's at first
oh one two one brendan rodgers
the pitch to him swinging in a miss
another good breaking ball and rogers
could have swung twice at that one and
he missed it but you know sensatella
when he's on he's pounding the strike
zone and there's a lot of ground balls
and he's also looking for his first road
win this year one out on the line drive
that's david peralta 2-1 pitch to
peralta is hit towards center field
coming on and making the grab about knee
high garrett hampson for the second out
good jump on that one by garrett now too
odd and one out for antonio senza telus
good bunt by santa
boy
so antonio gets attaboy from the dugout
good and two in scoring position for
rymel tapia
on the ground right at escobar there's
the ground ball and castigatos once
again has to work but puts a zero on the
board laid out banned on now for stu but
cabrez
on the ground and smothered by rogers at
second and they got the force on walker
really good plays brendan rodgers with
that diving stop and then trevor story
to keep his foot on the bag as christian
walker comes storming into second base
two on for nick almond
off the middle over the mound and throw
into center
cabrera coming around third and the
diamondbacks strike first well placed
ground ball that time off the bat and
nick ahmed
him on a slider right out there on the
outside corner he stays with it sends it
right back where it came from
one-nothing d-backs here's dalton varsio
smith charlie blackman comes up throwing
into third it's two nothing diamondbacks
building an inning yeah got pulled a
little bit but extends his swing hits
that hard ground ball through the right
side blacks diana's with his maiden
voyage at the plate here ahmed's at
third var shows it first
how about that
hampson on the bow vande runs it down
roberto castellanos drives in a run it's
three nothing
fastball right down the middle and he
tagged this ball that was a nice play by
hampson to catch that sends a telegow
whiplash when he looked at that ball as
it went
is the catcher
ground ball to short ahmed backhand goes
to escobar at second and then on to
first getting any double play nice turn
there by nick
and a nice pivot by escobar
three on the double play
pavon smith with a single his first time
it's good pitch by senza he strikes out
pavin smith third strike out of the ball
game for sensatella
see the late movement on that that was
great gonna get a pinch hitter andrew
young is gonna bat for castillanos the
right side and the o2 pitch is a
fastball for a called strike three
antonio senzatella just zipped it by
andrew young 19 appearances for matt
seven starts six pitches
and he disposes of sends a teller to
open up the fifth
that didn't take long here's tapia who
has walked in grounded to second tonight
50 runs 39 rbis he strikes out he was no
match for peacock there that's coming
let's strike out the first two on the
fifth inning peacock on top of his game
earl
might want to stick with a fastball here
two batters two strikeouts flying out in
a strikeout tonight for rojas
and now a ground out we think that's a
nice play he's made two to his left
tonight
that one off the bat at rojas he had
that one in the second inning off of as
druval cabrera where he's able to get
the lead runner christian walker
now on the outside corner walker called
out three nothing arizona leading as we
go to the bottom of the sixth inning
this is a hard hit ball and in the
outfield that is rogers on the spot
yeah tip the cap
if i had one on i'd take mine off also
he's made three
really fine plays tonight a seventh
ground ball out tonight too for senza a
rangefinder
cabrera out of the box
not an easy throw either no it's not
where he is located now body control the
the ability to pick up your target and
make an accurate throw as you're
spinning peacock has worked a scoreless
fifth and sixth but now he'll face the
catcher elias diaz to start the colorado
seven
for pitchers 146. this ball is lifted to
deep left field take a good look you
won't see it for long
rockies are on the board
stay hot elias diaz
my goodness his seventh home run
he has been a different offensive player
the last 10 days
sometimes it doesn't matter if it's a
fastball or a hanging breaking pitch
because this one went 426 feet what a
moment for stewart fairchild 25 year old
his first major league at bat right here
get down ball come on
rymel topia can't make the catch
and stuart fairchild's got a hit in the
big leagues he'll never forget it with a
great effort out there by rymel tapia
but fortunately for stuart fairchild and
the diamondbacks that comes popping out
as he went into that somersault out
there eduardo escobar has singled twice
two for three he's got stewart fairchild
at second base josh rojas at first and
one out
and warno hits a high fly ball
deep right field hey it's gone
there's the big one we've been waiting
for abdellafica eduardo escobar makes it
6-1 the d-max all-star pads that lead
that ball was absolutely blasted right
there a high velocity fastball from
tyler kinley up in the zone at 95. he
knew it right away rocky's now at second
and third
runner
is diving back in blackman and he'll
take advantage and go
to the plate six to two farsho for 2-2
on mcmahon rogers now at third and this
ball's hit well to left field really
well
and it's going to take a hop and go out
of play so it'll be an rbi double
and it's six to three and now things are
getting interesting nice job in this
hole at bat battling krone comes to the
plate two runs into the ending runner
it's second nobody out
ground ball through the middle
mcmahon around third he'll score it six
to four two big outs right there
trevor's story last man standing for
colorado
ball game diamondbacks win it six to
four
last time they won a series may 2nd last
time they won back-to-back games made
10th and 11th they just did both